400 to a thousand dollars this is how
much you can make per article by writing
about Banks presidents and other notable
figures on Wikipedia
that's why teachers told us not to trust
what we see on Wikipedia after all
anyone can change it but have you
actually ever seen someone edit or
change a Wikipedia article I know I
haven't but somehow there's a Wikipedia
article about virtually any topic that
you can think of whether that be
President Calvin coolidge's pet raccoon
or food mechanics in fact according to a
Wikipedia page there's a total of 58
million Wikipedia Pages traditionally
these articles are written by super
dedicated volunteers people who strongly
believe in the free sharing of
information like this guy this guy
Stephen Pruitt has apparently made
nearly 3 million edits on Wikipedia and
written 35 000 original articles all for
no compensation he says that the idea of
making it all free fascinates him but
not all Wikipedia writers are quite as
Noble here's the thing the influence of
Wikipedia has grown tremendously over
the past 20 years nowadays the
information found on Wikipedia is often
taken as gospel because oftentimes you
don't even know that it's from Wikipedia
take voice assistance for example
whether you're asking Alexa Google or
Siri much of the information you're
consuming is directly from Wikipedia the
same thing is true for chat GPT as well
which has been trained using the
entirety of Wikipedia in fact companies
use Wikipedia so much that Wikipedia's
parent organization Wikimedia has
actually started charging companies for
using Wikipedia and their first customer
was none other than Google themselves
this in itself has raised concerns about
how these big tech companies can
exercise control over Wikipedia but more
importantly this has added an
Indescribable amount of credibility to
Wikipedia all of a sudden writing for
Wikipedia isn't just a case of
contributing to some online Forum it's a
case of defining the truth as what you
write will be repeated by billions of
voice assistants and generative AIS
around the world I think you can start
to see why this would be an extremely
valuable resource to push a certain
narrative welcome to the black market of
Wikipedia
foreign
Wikipedia articles to push a certain
narrative can be super lucrative but
getting into the business isn't all that
easy according to teachers publishing
articles is something that is just about
any random joke can do but that's
actually completely false in fact the
process of publishing to Wikipedia is
extremely hard and long especially for
new accounts which is where you probably
have to start I bet that Wikipedia is
one of the only services that you use on
a regular basis but don't have an
account for anyway once you create an
account you'll be greeted by this page
which is basically a dashboard to track
your social credit on Wikipedia as you
can see I have a none but this is where
you'll have to start if you want again
to publishing actual articles first
Wikipedia will suggest a bunch of
articles for you to make small edits to
in terms of spelling grammar and a tone
you'll have to edit at least 10 pages
before you unlock publishing
functionality but if you don't want to
see him says you'll likely want to make
hundreds if not thousands of added
before writing full-on articles once you
build up this Wikipedia credit
congratulations you can finally start
writing your very own articles and
publish them into the ether wait never
mind it's not that easy even after you
build up Social credit on Wikipedia you
can't just publish articles or I I guess
you can but it doesn't actually get
published when you press publish instead
it gets added to a massive queue of over
4 000 articles waiting to be published
it usually takes about six months to get
through this Cura after which your
article will go through a rather arduous
verification process the number one
factor that Wikipedia is looking for
when approving articles is notability no
amount of fancy writing or editing will
get you around this requirement in fact
Wikipedia deletes and rejects over 200
articles every single day because they
lack notability how do they determine
notability well it comes down to how
many independent articles already exist
regarding the subject corporate press
releases and websites do not count
notability for obvious reasons Wikipedia
is looking for at least three high
quality sources that contain substantial
discussion about the topic a simple
mention it is not sufficient they're
also scanning for any sort of evident
bias or narrative that you're trying to
push these rules are already pretty
stringent if you're writing about an
organization or event but if you decide
to write about a person the scrutiny
increases several fold the reason being
that Wikipedia wants to avoid libel and
slander which was notoriously common
back in the early days in fact at one
point in time Wikipedia claimed that
Tony Blair the former prime minister of
the UK worshiped Mr small mustache
nowadays this wouldn't fly because each
and every line about a living person has
to have a direct reference if it doesn't
it gets removed even if it's accurate
all of that just scratches the surface
of Wikipedia's verification process but
if you're able to get through the
gauntlet well now you're finally in
business
unlike the process of publishing an
article finding people who are willing
to pay for an article isn't that hard
for obvious reasons companies and people
of Interest are incentivized to write
articles about themselves to increase
their notoriety but this is something
that most people and organizations avoid
doing themselves because of the
repercussions writing articles about
yourself is strictly prohibited as
that's a clear conflict of interest if
Wikipedia's reviewer sends that a given
article was written by an affiliate not
only is the article taken down but the
topic is flagged making it even harder
for future articles to be published
about the same topic this is why many
companies turn to a professional service
on prieti that specializes in this art
such businesses have a team of Wikipedia
editors with a bunch of social credit to
push articles that clients want one such
business is a Wikipedia tribe their
pitched on the main page is literally
hire a certified Wikipedia consultants
and and it claim the fame there are
certain parts of the page that almost
make the page seem legit for example
they claim that they do exhaustive
research and utilize domain experts to
get authentic information but just below
that you run into statements like this
are certified Wikipedia experts have a
complete Command on the exhaustive wiki
guidelines so they can get approval on
the first run now why exactly would a
legitimate article be worried about
getting approval obviously no reason at
all the reality is that the entire site
is designed to convince customers about
why Wikipedia pages are so important
even more important than Google and why
clients should invest in creating a page
that will surely get approved from an
outside perspective this is obviously
super sketchy but the thing to keep in
mind is that the people who are looking
for this service are indeed looking for
something sketchy so it works out
perfectly I mean according to their
stats it looks like business is booming
Wikipedia Thrive apparently has a 15
1000 edits six thousand Live profiles
and 50 000 satisfied clients even if we
assume that each client was only charged
a hundred dollars we're talking about
five million dollars in Revenue but
that's honestly lowballing it way back
in 2015 a freelance writer named Mike
Woody claimed that clients pay him 400
to a thousand dollars per article so
eight years later that rate has likely
only gone up even at 400 we're talking
about a 20 million dollars in Revenue at
a thousand dollars we're talking about
as much as fifty million dollars in
revenue and that's just one business
there's dozens just like this this one
company called it Wiki experts Inc for
example is apparently ranked as the
number one wikipedians company they
claim to have published 4 900 articles
for 3 400 clients over the past 10 years
and their motto is your Global Fame is
Just One Call Away some other businesses
include Wiki counselor Wiki native wiki
consultancy wiki consultant American
Wiki editors and lumino just to name few
some are more sketchy than others but
none are as sketchy as a true White Club
service
most of the businesses we've covered so
far are definitely sketchy but they're
not full-on propaganda machines those
simply cherry pick sources that support
a given narrative and write articles
using these sources but some more white
glove Services we'll just go ahead and
create these sources themselves which
brings us into the world of paid media
getting paid media itself is not that
hard there are legitimate ways to make
sponsored posts and or get press
releases featured on sites like Forbes
and CNBC but the problem with these
Avenues is that Wikipedia does not
accept sponsored posts or press releases
as valid sources so ironically getting a
Wikipedia page is actually harder than
being featured in mainstream media to
get into Wikipedia not only do you have
to be featured on such websites in a
substantial manner but you have to be
featured in a seemingly natural and
independent manner this is where PR
agencies like spinic come into to play
the way this works is pretty simple
these companies basically have a bunch
of connections with writers who work
these outlets and they pay them a fee to
cover certain topics spin has
connections with all of the following
Outlets theoretically speaking the
writers are the one who have control of
what ends up getting published but this
really just comes down to the ethics of
the given Rider there's obviously going
to be writers who are willing to post
anything for the right price at spin for
example you can get one story on Yahoo
finance or Business Insider for a
thousand dollars they're so confident in
their abilities that they even offer a
money back guarantee for three thousand
dollars a month they can get you into
six Publications within three months so
it's really nine thousand in total and
finally for 5 000 a month they can get
you into 12 Publications within three
months so for 15 000 in total let's just
say that this business is also booming
and spin has been able to generate 30
million dollars worth of Revenue within
just two years of launching it looks
looks like there's a lot of egomaniacs
out there that are desperate for
publicity and attention anyway if you're
looking to get into Wikipedia from
nothing you probably want to opt for the
Enterprise package so we're talking
about 15 grand after that you'll also
have to pay a thousand or so for the
Wikipedia article itself so we're
talking about a total of 16 Grand that's
the prize to get into Wikipedia without
any prior notoriety but just because you
get your Wikipedia article posted it
doesn't mean that you're safe once the
article is posted Wikipedia will
continue to monitor the interest on your
page and other writers will be able to
suggest changes if your page doesn't get
much interest and no one suggests any
changes that in itself will be a major
red flag after all what type of person
who is featured in 12 Publications
within a matter of three months gets
only 7 views on their Wikipedia page no
man at all Wikipedia Bots are constantly
on the lookout for such pages in fact
they take down 1 000 such pages on a
daily basis so if you want to keep your
Wikipedia page up you'll have to start
paying for Bots to view your page but
not simply the price you have to pay if
you're trying to buy your way to fame as
this is the black market of Wikipedia
someone else that's devoted to the free
sharing of information is the founders
of the Pirate Bay if you want to hear
about their legendary story check out
this video but until then I'm already
and I'll see you guys on the next one
foreign